on parlait de cet accord nous recevons
jean paul chang économiste et
spécialiste de la chine mon jour
monsieur charles merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors on parle d'un d'une étape
historique en tout cas c'est ce que a
déclaré donald trump est également le
vice président chinois mais ce que c'est
une véritable avancée parce qu'on sent
les économistes plus sceptique sur la
question disons que c'est une étape
significative qui représente quand même
un certain apaisement après 22 mois de
guerre commerciale entre les deux
premières puissances économiques du
monde
dire que c'est historique on verra est
ce que ce sera une étape suffisant pour
restaurer totalement ils me sortent des
relations de confiance entre la chine et
les états unis on verra aussi dans
l'exécution de ces accords il y aura
probablement des problèmes qui vont
surgir
il ya un mécanisme pour régler les
disputes éventuelles il faut voir aussi
si si ça va fonctionner il est clair que
dans la période électorale qui s'ouvre
aux états unis c'est un très bon point
pour le président entre m on parle d'une
première phase de l'accord quoi ça
consiste réellement et comment ça va se
poursuivre
là on parle d'une première phase qui est
composé essentiellement des objectifs
très précis il ya plus de 90 pages
finalement d'accord d'accord très précis
par secteur avec des objectifs
quantitatifs d'importation de produits
américains que les chinois se sont
engagés à respecter est là
on parle pas de deuxième phase on dit
que la deuxième phase va être négocié
incessamment sous peu
cela porterait probablement plus sur les
problèmes de compatibilité entre les
deux systèmes économiques parce que les
américains voulu que le chinois réforme
davantage la modèle économique
or ça ça touche beaucoup les problèmes
de souveraineté pour la chine qui est
très fier de son modèle économique et
n'entend pas beaucoup de changer
justement la chine elle a assuré qu'elle
poursuivrait des réformes pour s'ouvrir
davantage au monde
alors ce conflit sino américain à la
vertu d'accélérer peut-être des mesures
dans l'effort certains le secteur
notamment au secteur financier des
réformes dans lesquels de la chine
s'était engagée toute façon mais là
cette fois-ci effectivement dans ces
accords il prévoit dans un délai de cinq
mois d'ouverture du secteur financier
aux firmes américaines
donc la chine s'est ainsi engagée à
acheter des services financiers
américain pour un montant de près de 40
milliards ce qui est considérable mais
cela n'est pas incompatible vision avec
avec eux les réformes qu envisagée les
chinois de toute façon qui va profiter
le plus les lit sinon les américains
parce que c'est gagnant gagnant
alors c'est les chinois ont dû faire
beaucoup de concessions parce que 200
milliards sur deux ans certes c'est
complètement absorbable par par la chine
la chine apporte quelque chose comme
1500 milliards 2,2 d'importation du
monde entier donc 10 milliards 100
milliards par an 200 milliards sur deux
ans ce n'est pas énorme
c'est absorbable mais c'est quand même
des concessions que les chinois en fait
ceci dit tout le monde va en bénéficier
l'apaisement de l'atmosphère entre les
deux permettra probablement à les
entreprises chinoises n'ont pas subi à
davantage de hausse des tarifs douaniers
américains et pour les entreprises
américaines côte est de se sentir un peu
plus stabilisée dans le choix à venir
pour les années à venir
vous l'avez dit on est là on va bientôt
entrer dans une période électorale aux
états unis avec ce sont vingt secondes
peut-être second mandat de donald trump
est ce que c'était important justement
pour le président américain de d'apaiser
les tensions
maintenant ça le timing je pense que
pour le président il s'agit surtout
d'avoir une victoire en tout cas une
réalisation a montré du côté chinois
effectivement ils ont ils sont très
compréhensifs donc ils comprennent très
bien qu effectivement que de la trappe
un besoin de cet accord et c'est pour ça
ils ont accepté d'augmenter notamment
l'importation des produits agricoles
américains
sachant que cela représente à terme une
satisfaction pour un électorat important
du bruit d'entraînement on parle
également de propriété intellectuelle ou
encore de subventions aux entreprises
publiques
quelles vont être les principaux
dossiers à régler entre les deux
puissances économiques alors qu'il par
le présent accord parle déjà de
respecter finalement les règles du
marché des règles commerciales et de du
volontariat en termes de transferts
technologie donc la chine s'engage à ne
pas exiger dans le cas des
investissements étrangers le transfert
de technologie deuxièmement probablement
mais on connaît pas le détail la chine
bat d'accord pour payer un certain
nombre de licences sur lesquelles je
pense que les chenaux un peu de retard
donc les chinois acceptent aujourd'hui
le set là que la première intellectuelle
fait partie du concept des matières
premières finalement dans les produits
qui sont commercialisés très bien merci
beaucoup monsieur jean-paul changement
nous avoir éclairé ans sur cet accord
entre washington et pékin pour mettre
fin à cette guerre commerciale que se
livrent les deux pays je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste et spécialiste
merci